[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this of course the segment where viewers
try to find mistakes on our show so far
many many challengers no winners we've
never made a mistake yeah
well tonight tonight a fan named Eric
Boyd thinks he caught a mistake he says
it happened during our recent sketch
about the next Star Wars movie when we
wondered what would be like if Michael
Moore got to directed here's the
schedule come and I found a mistake in
your sketch called Vader in me in the
sketch of stormtrooper tells Michael
Moore that darth vader is vacationing on
the planet Endor are you aware that
Darth Vader has destroyed thousands of
jobs on my home planet of flint doing
and I want to answer
I'm sorry sir mr. Rayner is vacationing
with his family on the planet Endor the
planet Endor really Conan are you sure
about that because it doesn't take a
genius IQ or a high medic or need
account to know that the planet endures
the gas giant and has a composition
similar to that of Jupiter and Saturn
and therefore has no surface and it
would be impossible for anyone even a
Sith Lord as powerful it starts Vader to
vacation when you meant to state that
Darth Vader was vacationing on one of
the moons of Endor such as the forest
moon of Endor which is where the he
walks with a mistake like this is surely
an insult seriously dudes show some
respect
[Applause]
well I'm sorry Eric I'm also
particularly sorry that you apparently
are in the hospital and not an expensive
faucet deeper also you are dead wrong
dude
Darth Vader could indeed vacation on the
planet Endor you doubt me well here's a
response from the man himself
Eric Boyd said no one could paycation on
the surface of n dot because it is a gas
giant that is true but i'm not on the
surface you blend you'll sandworm all
gas giants have solid cores and that's
where i am now at the core of Endor
Resort and Spa it's the ideal location
for a secret rendezvous send in another
fan correction
[Applause]
[Music]
find more about Darth Vader everyday
what a challenge so stanchions think you
spotted an error on our show reported at
team koco.com / haha I found an error we
will store that right here on the air
let's see if you've got what it takes to
make chunk meat out of the maestro